bien disposés à 11 204 jours aujourd'hui
c'est pas toi ces quatre jeux voilà
c'est on s'en bat les couilles
on commence avec dress code human stage
ou extrêmement simple on va juste devoir
habiller un squelette montgallet on en a
marre des zélés sur m6 où émergent des
vêtements la nommait de la peau sur les
os d'accord c'est un peu ça lâche pas
vous mentir je me sens un peu mal à
temps mais deux minutes c'est chaud mon
gars ok [ __ ] fait qantas s'est
beaucoup appuyé de merde sur le mur j'ai
sali le mur ah pardon
quand j'ai mis la chair je suis plaisait
je peux plus la retirer quoi j'ai
intérêt à gérer juste l'absence de me
coller de pommes de terre partout sur le
corps actuellement mais je suis en train
de prendre beaucoup de plaisir avec
l'appui de polar c'est fini oui on met
les yeux mais c'est magnifique à cefrio
ya suivant ah oui celle-là est parfaite
saleh parfaite voilà ça fait kiffer les
filles s'adonnent petit sourire d'un
homme qui fait rire c'est très bien au
non j'aime ton seigneur est avec je veux
cela la place voilà il nous faut un pif
en est un pif arrête de bouger avec en
turquie sa vie si tu bouges la super
chiant mer des oreilles puis même si on
s'en fout pas important ça allait on lui
met la plus grande peur comme ça il
entendra au loin à te adage tribale mais
oui c'est magnifique avec un tatouage de
chat sur mollet et un couteau sur le
bras on est bon ok les cheveux des
cheveux blancs une barre de hipsters
aussi beau que tu prouves elle est prêt
à faire la fête
ouais attendent le carreau puisque les
deux autres pays dans la gérer on a
failli monumentale mais quand ces [ __ ]
et un franchement je me plais marque
blanche elle fait graves et jeux
suivants
ok on est mana surprise un poil en un
mot ça super héros est un travail main
dans une prison c'est une retraite
normalement un super-héros finalement il
va devoir remettre les prisonniers de
leur cellule parce qu'ils font que de la
merde à il faut les zigotos j'ai pas dit
ça depuis 2008 donc on va les stopper
c'est quoi quels sont les touches
d'accord donc chasser un gardien
efficace des [ __ ] mais c'est ça le
haut
oui viala via la wii mais qui envoie des
bons mecs de la prison je vais défoncer
jeunes et ça va tuer salako shdm en
attraper un enjeu l'est je laisse aux
bouquins comme enjeu le dira
faut qu'on leur amène bien par la piste
de [ __ ] open door vient la haye mais se
laisse pas faire tu arrêtes tu vois ta
cellule à fils de [ __ ]
non mais tu fais quoi et de ah tiens un
petit [ __ ] je suis fait quoi toi
allait bien mais quand à gérer à gardien
efficace allait bien par la tient non
suivant tiens tiens tu te tuer je fais
le bolide est mon gars faisait pas ça
pour son gardien
et ça dégage ok on est bien oui ces
moments bel 20 prend 2
[Applaudissements]
oh là là regardez cette beauté et bien
là auch et y ait eu ce coup comme un sac
à merde ça dégage voilà allez hop
suivant balayage rigole pas m'arrêter
rien ne peut m'arrêter allez hop suivant
là je te prends eh bien allez bien ah
non je viens son furet mais toi toi t'es
mort toi viala a les boules hausse vient
pas la haye plus qu'à quatre longueurs
on est promu c'est quoi ce délire
maintenant mais je suis beau gala
genzyme coincé dans le mur mais non mais
j'ai de quoi s'alarmer non opus non au
pôle nord menacent pas là
et ma jambe dans ce mur et ça c'est un
mec super héros ça ait jamais vues à
rodman avec une jambe bloquée dans le
mur a non mais du coup il ya tout à
refaire max et rôle où tu reste à terre
ah je me suis cassé puis j'ai coaché le
pire héros du mot bigot j'ai eu ça aille
bien là on ces violences que je l'aimé
tu dégages vous arrêtez votre petit jeu
bande de grosse merde
et toi tu viens du fossé viol aux exclus
aux plages va lequel je prends ces
horribles à vis de sommeil qui va finir
avec une [ __ ] de scoliose c'est
terrible bla bla aller [ __ ] je peux le
faire là j'en ai marre oui on fait ça
bien avec lui on a fait ça dans les
règles
abba parfait monga livraison chronopost
c'est parti ça dégage allègrement au
revoir on s'est mis bien on se mettrait
très bien les amis bienvenue dans
youtube rétro à l'heure où la 4 4
comment cette danse 0,1 pour cent des
foyers nous allons faire tout l'inversé
de dire regardez des choses en hd par en
hd je chante pas doué en tant que marque
bref on gronde à une télé ici on a eu
tube par exemple on va taper jean-michel
sur youtube heures que j'apprécie
grandement et va vouloir garder la média
compile des jean-michel avec kad merad
quand je fais ensuite absent c'est dur
[Musique]
finalement j'aime bien la 4k qui marche
bien comme il faut ce que j'ai réussi à
temps
requête acceptée du rôdeur will be
dispatch est souvent aux [ __ ] choix
j'ai réussi c'est pas si simple que pour
regarder vidéos youtube dans la vraie
vie alors j'ai commandé une cassette où
est la cassette [ __ ] j'ai eu droit au
vidéo club en 2004 là où la cassette
vidéo des livres et merci d'avoir
utilisé youtube à bâle avec à cette
[ __ ] du coup là ont surtout réclamé à
compiler jean-michel on va la mettre là
et voilà la vidéo youtube appareils sur
cette petite télé la compilation des
chanteurs inconnus pour la première fois
que des chanteurs pas connu du tout
il ne chante que 50% de ses chansons
préférées c'est jean-michel à moitié
c'est un bon
c'est une
pis la meilleure vidéo du monde pour ce
jeu quoi ok ok et si je prends une vidéo
récente par exemple est en train de
faire la commande de la cassette avec le
[ __ ] de kad merad en fait c'est une
horreur cette vidéo on est en train
d'attendre la cassette
j'en ai marre de ces chansons vidéos
délivré aux [ __ ] howie à l'ancienne
fred a tancé l'intérêt est donc de
regarder une vidéo pour acheter encore
plus dégueulasse pour 249 fantastique
sanaa il manque un peu juste surtout en
réalité virtuelle et c'est on est juste
plus haut que jamais web annonce urines
crédit ped
après un jeu qui n'a aucun intérêt un
jeu qui a un petit intérêt au cauchemar
le premier niveau et c'est une sorte de
coup hop sauf que tu joues à mons
dégueulasse vert mais vraiment
dégueulasse voilà bon j'ai déjà envie de
passer au jeu suivant ok il faut qu'il
ait touché une cerise c'est ça non mais
mec jamais il marchera jamais marchera à
ok non mais je repars dans l'autobus
on en est là on est au premier niveau et
on en est là déjà ce truc dans ressemble
à rien mon gars on dirait un coton-tige
mecs avec une paire de testicules je
suis désolé mais c'est la vérité comme
le perso jeu vidéo le plus laid de tous
les [ __ ] de temps trouve la pomme
l'objectif de jeu vidéo le plus
incroyable au monde on doit trouver la
pomme à vue il sait pas même mon monstre
à la pomme s'envolait sait pas bien si
c'est bon
super ah on peut ajouter les muscles
nous mêmes
voyez on peut dire ici je veux un muscle
qui va dans ce sens et ici je veux un
muscle qui va dans ce sens voilà je sais
pas ce que j'ai fait mais ça a l'air
cool c'est super j'ai fait un super
monstre jeu peut être joué à une main
comme sur téléphone génial les muscs
avec cela bouge à l'opposé les muscs
avec ça va on a compris ça arrive un peu
tard cette explication
qu'est ce que je suis en train de faire
avec ma vie là qu est ce qui fait qu est
ce que je suis entre mes mecs mais à
allauch d'accord je comprends je fais
pas ta place place ma copine qui m'a
largué franchement vrai en vrai est-ce
que youtube rétro ce n'est pas quand
même mieux
est-ce que se met une petite cassette
c'est pas la meilleure chose qui pouvait
aller dans cette vidéo mais franchement
ils étaient de petites sommes pirouette
cacahuète
il était un petit homme qui avait
dans le maison
avait une drôle de maison
ouais je suis atteinte cette petite
compilation de jeux ça m'a bien fait
marrer jetables ou si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas et veulent à vis de théo
voilà je pense qu'on a fini sur une note
génial clairement rétro youtube s'impose
comme le meilleur jeu de cette vidéo ça
m'indique bien le niveau de cette vidéo
quand même savoir garder en santé de
cette prochaine vidéo portez vous bien
[Musique]
à mano à mano